et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre roger secrétaire national cf cgc
bonsoir s'est arrogé merci d'être avec
nous premiers jours de conférences du
financement elle était très attendue
vous y avaient participé
racontez-nous vous partager le même
point de vue que votre collègue l'enjeu
est de taille ça va être difficile à
écouter bon j'entends j'entends ce qu'a
dit mon collègue juste avant le début de
la conférence est lorsqu'on participe à
une négociation en principe ce pour
essayer d'aller au bout
ceci étant dit il faut quand même
rappeler le contexte de cette
négociation
elle a été lancée pour d'une part
exprimé que la seule solution viable
pour le gouvernement c'est la sienne en
fixant cette conférence le cadre a été
fixé très court comme délai vous ne
touchez pas au niveau des pensions ça
nous pose pas de problème vous touchez
pas au niveau de cotisation donc il
reste un seul paramètre la durée si vous
trouver une autre solution que la shd
équilibre tel que je le propose je suis
preneur
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça vous
comprenez que c'est le show est
relativement étroit
surtout qu'aujourd'hui l'objectif
c'était de voir quelle était l'ampleur
de la situation
l'ampleur de la situation elle est très
simple j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire sur
votre plateau ici même il ya pas un
problème de finances si y'a pas de
problème de retraite à 2027 il ya
simplement un problème de recettes ou
l'état a décidé de ne plus apporter sa
contribution comme aujourd'hui donc de
ce fait sacrer un déficit est ce que
pour autant ces graves
alors je rappelle quand même que on
parle de 12 milliards à l'horizon 2027
par an en face leurs traites c300 325
milliards chaque année et on à 140
milliards de réserve par ailleurs leur
forme en 2024 fin 2024 la cades est la
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale aura totalement remboursé la
dette et ça libère par an environ 17
milliards pris comme ça est ce qu'on est
obligé nécessairement le pr
ur uniquement sur l'âge nous on pense
qu'on peut trouver une autre solution ce
qui est frappant dans cette conférence
c'est que tout le monde ya participé
oui sauf l'état employeur c'est à dire
qu'il n'y avait pas de représentant de
l'état cet après midi alors qu en tant
qu'employeur financement parlant du
financement vous aviez des membres de
l'êta qui étaient des fonctionnaires la
cour des comptes et autres qui étaient
là en tant qu'expert à deux
représentants ait pas de représentant de
l'état en tant qu'employeur pourrait
mettre son son son avis alors que vous
aviez finalement film autour de la table
tous les représentants syndicaux que ce
soit du côté patronal ou salariés du
secteur privé donc dit pierre roger ça
veut dire concrètement qu on comprenne
bien parce que l'on a prévu la chance
d'y être cette conférence qui
représentait l'état cet après midi bien
on laisse on nous laisse certainement
qu'il faut interpréter ça comme une
marque de confiance
le soin de traiter le problème du
gouvernement qui nous dit bah écoute et
voilà moi j'arrête de financer parce que
j'ai moins de fonctionnaires donc je
paye moi j'ai fait des exonérations de
cotisations donc je sais qu'on pense pas
contrairement à ce que la loi avait
prévu je vous donne
d'après mes calculs alors là aussi
l'estimation des 2 milliards on l'a
quand même regarder un petit peu dans le
détail elle est très optimiste quand
même mais elle est trop optimiste
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on a une
croissance à 1,3 qui en moyenne prévu
sur la période c'est pas évident quand
on voit le passé un chômage à 7%
on c'est vrai qu'il ya une tendance un
peu à l'amélioration mais surtout à un
gain de productivité de productivité par
dont 1,5 or on n'y est pas du tout un 5
1 % ce grand maximum pourquoi parce que
la france crée des emplois aujourd'hui
mais ce sont des emplois de qualité très
moyenne
je veux dire en creux d
et les livreurs délire ou alors j'ai
absolument rien contre les garçons qui
font ou des filles qui font ce genre de
travail mais c'est pas des ingénieurs en
termes de croissance de productivité
elle n'a pas la même portée sa baisse le
chômage c'est une bonne chose ça
n'apporte pas des revenus suffisants au
long terme donc la prévision du
gouvernement et on va dire qualifié 2 et
là dessus tout le monde a pris à la
corde très optimistes relativement
optimiste ceci étant ça remet pas les
choses au fond avec tout ce que je vous
ai dit on a les moyens de financer
simplement la volonté politique elle est
clair c'est de dire que je veux faire
une réduction des déficits de l'état
en tant qu'employeur la solution que je
propose c'est de reporter l'âge selon
des modalités et dash déquilibre à
discuter en cours de discussion au
niveau de l'assemblée nationale et il
n'y a pas d'autre solution pour moi qui
est envisageable
en tout cas si vous la proposer j'aurai
la liberté c'est prévu dans le texte de
la refusez donc à la lumière de ce que
vous nous dites on se demande comment
les choses pourront avancer puisque on
se souvient du postulat de départ c'est
à vous trouver les solutions si vous les
trouvez pas il y aura bien cet âge pivot
qui sera imposée par le gouvernement on
est bien d'accord
c'est absolument ça est donc à l'image
de la conférence d'aujourd'hui qui alla
ce matin a duré trois heures on a deux
séries donc ce financement on doit le
trouver en trois séances
tous trois heures sachant que la séance
de ce matin on nous a communiqué des
éléments vendredi qu'on connecte tous
par coeur nous a déjà expliqué pendant
une heure et demie les slides qu'on
connaît tous par coeur ce qui fait que
pour commencer la discussion
organisation grosso modo vous avez 10 à
15 minutes
si on fait trois séances pour trouver
quelques milliards à raison d'un quart
d'heure organisation en trois séances
voyez bien que il faut qu'on se mettre
d'accord en 45 minutes chacun ça va être
ça va être compliqué ça veut dire qu'un
roger concrètement aujourd'hui
à l'heure où vous nous parlez ll très
cette première journée que vous êtes
pessimiste que vous avez l'impression
qu'en gros il n'y a pas vraiment de
négociation dans le réel
le message que je veux faire passer
c'est que on a à côté 1
une assemblée nationale qui fait son
rôle en tant que l'assemblée nationale
de discuter des amendements qui peuvent
entraîner des modifications du texte de
loi avec des conséquences financières
vous y croyez ça tant qu' on peut très
bien aggraver la situation
on porterait l'améliorer mais bon ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que
l'assemblée fait son travail de fin au
niveau législatif qui est normal nous à
côté on parle financement et que ça se
fait de manière parallèle sans enfant
coordination par définition puisque nous
ne sommes pas les deux représentants de
la nation au niveau des six latif et que
eux mêmes n'ont pas les éléments pour
discuter du financement
avouez quand même que c'est une démarche
un peu curieuse
donc comme je voulais d une négociation
ouverte une discussion ouverte nous y
allons avec toute la bonne foi ça
n'empêche pas d'être lucide on s'est pas
donné les moyens clairement d'aboutir en
tout cas c'est pas comme ça qu'on a on
ne sait pas la première impression que
cela donne bien roger vous avez décidé
dans votre syndicat la cgt de ces feux
pardon cgc de ne plus vous mobiliser
mais tout de même de rester dans
l'intersyndicale si ça ne devait pas
aboutir
quel serait votre choix vos actions
alors le choix toute façon il appartient
au moment où on devra discuter en
fonction de l'évolution des choses parce
que je constate aujourd'hui c'est quand
même pendant l'alignement des planètes
un petit peu bizarre vous avez
effectivement une intersyndicale vous
avez à côté des professions libérales
des avocats encore ce matin dans cette
conférence la représentants sont
clairement exprimé en disant mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait là on n'a rien demandé
vous avez le medef qui représente les
grandes entreprises qui dit nous on
n'est pas le vendeur de cette réforme
et quand on dit que sur le financement
on veut maintenir
plafond des cotisations entre 3 et 8
plafonds
vous avez un alignement de planètes qui
fait que la cgt est d'accord la cfe cgc
qui représente les cadres est d'accord
au départ pourtant ce ne sont pas deux
organisations a priori qui ont
l'habitude d'avoir le même point et le
medef est d'accord moi je pose la
question lorsque vous avez la cgt la cfe
et le medef qui ont les mêmes analyses
et qui arrive aux mêmes conclusions
c'est peut-être au niveau du programme
et à peut-être un loup parle tout cas ça
mérite qu'on se pose la question
visiblement c'est un gouvernement qui
n'a absolument pas envie de changer de
posture qui n'a qu'une hâte c'était
faire passer ses textes au plus vite et
de passer à autre chose en tout cas
c'est l'impression que ça donne
le fait que agnès buzyn été remplacé par
olivier ferrand
quelle est votre réaction ça peut ouvrir
peut-être une piste ou au contraire
ou alors ça ne change rien pour moi je
pense pas que ça change parce que toute
façon ce texte jette au niveau du
premier ministre est qu'il assimile l'a
conçu et l'assument c'est clair et net
on l'a vu au fur et à mesure des
remplacements des ministres je pense que
je peux pas parler pour madame busin
mais je pense qu'elle n'a pas vraiment
eu le choix de ce qu'on lui a demandé
ça fait partie des la grandeur de la
fonction voilà mai
bon c'est au niveau du premier ministre
les choses se passent et en dessous ce
n'est on le voit tous les jours que la
mise en forme
merci beaucoup en tout cas pierre anger
d'être venu nous raconter cette première
journée de la conférence de financer le
projet des retraites merci à vous